what's up reject nation in his eye
Jonathan Humphrey is actually not my
name is just John John coming at you and
with me today is my homegirl Bryn
brindle in it's not my name either
Britton did Steve Wozniak is here it's
me from the Apple Computer ah Bryn was
Nikki writer-director comedian
extraordinaire you're jack of Jill of
men you're Jill yeah some trades
yeah and you just directed a movie I did
that just dropped on where can people
find your movie it's called her side of
the bed it's on Amazon I don't know if
you've heard of it but it's this really
cool place or you can see lots of things
it's on prime video if you don't have
Prime you can rent it by a DVD if you
like to hold DVDs in your hands you know
go back to your I like to hold the DVDs
while I'm streaming things like that
tactile experience yes definitely you
know what else is a tactile experience
watching American Horror Story because
you know cuz usually some freakiest
happening so maybe you'll clutch your
pearls or maybe some sexy is happening
and so you know you'll watch your pearl
yeah we got the tease and also like a
full-on trailer for the new season of
American Horror Story I'm pretty because
I've heard a few things about it I
understand they're gonna cross a bunch
of things over so you know that's gonna
be exciting to check out but before we
hop into this trailer want to give a
quick shout out to someone whose life is
a real American Horror Story and that
would be Scuba Steve scuba steno we
often shout out Scuba Steve and we
talked about his badass graffiti art
which is badass out there in the streets
sticking it to the man making art but
also scoop Steve's a big horror fan and
he often appears in my bedroom at night
like in the nude literally he's there or
just in your fantasy no he showed he's
there he's like do you ever see the
hotels season with that guy with the no
eyes and the big spike it's a lot like
that but with Scoob which you know the
show this is actually really gruesome
[ __ ] but I've played that character once
at Universal Studios anyway let's let's
hop into this are you ready
all right we're gonna hop from one right
into the other here we go it's the end
of the world
[Music]
that's right favorite watches turns out
they did somebody else done baby
free upgrade with X plus yeah man that
okay I mean you know it's bite size that
looked pretty cool i I'm glad that I got
to the point in season 3 where I saw
that character die so I could be like oh
it's exciting that she'll be yeah be
like oh no are you ready for some more
all right here we go
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to outpost me the hospitals are
simple you may never leave the building
due to the danger of radiation
contamination and no unauthorized
copulation strangely satisfying easily
to dispensing punishments our world now
to remould as we see fit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I'm into it I don't know why I
always get a little skeptical every time
they're about to start a new season and
I'm like I don't know about this theme
and then I take a look at the trailer
wow that looks really in timing I really
like the Apocalypse imagery I mean it's
always very beautifully done just like
visually I love the idea of Sarah
Paulsen like being six character being
six characters but also one of her six
characters like rebuilding the world
like it's her dollhouse and she's yeah
one she's always hanging with Kathy
Bates oh yeah oh yeah well that's the
thing I mean like this trailer got me
wondering I feel like the first half I
was really intrigued by new content it's
got that like Ryan Murphy humor or the
guys like Ryan Murphy stuff I feel like
always gets a little hint of cheese just
like a thin layer of a brie on top of it
which is delicious cuz it's like it's
scary but things bug me when they take
themselves too seriously it and Ryan
Murphy is like I know this is cheesy in
here I'm gonna let you chew on that I
feel like there's a love of schlock and
B horror that kind of pervades the
underbelly of American Horror Story legs
up like you know they like to get messed
up most of the time but I do like those
elements and yes it's just the first
half with all this weird phenomena like
there's no pilot in the plane the planes
going down and then especially the
imagery or like the gas masks and these
trucks rolling up and like really dreary
color palette like that seemed like
something that would be kind of new for
American Horror Story because the thing
is I like the bunker I like the outpost
but especially having it so in-your-face
it's bringing back murder house and come
in and stuff I was like this reminds me
a lot of several seasons of America I'm
like here's a great symmetrical shot of
this beautiful structure you're
to be living in there's like a spiral
staircase there's gotta be a spiral
living in close quarters and not getting
along okay we're gonna see some Dutch
angles I assure you
Oh Dutch AF yeah that's gonna be totally
Bavarian and this makes me wondered how
they're gonna crash all these different
worlds together and also who in this
trailer belongs to which which Sarah
Paulson is which yes I'd like you know
do you think cuz it was kind of hard to
tell like do you think she's playing all
of her different characters that's in
the sense I've gotten from all the talk
they've done in all the advertising so
far I'm about it you know what I
realized though that I'm disturbed by it
I did not see a Jessica Lange in there
at all
no they're keeping that probably pretty
close to the chest I guess cuz it's
confirmed that she's gonna be bad oh it
is oh yeah I'm claiming this one I'm
pretty close to the judge I think yeah
they said she's coming back and I don't
know if she's gonna reprise both of her
characters or what but you know she's
definitely prominent in both all your
characters we're kind of the same
they're always like strong badass sassy
matriarch yeah like kind of evil but we
like her anyway evil but you get why
usually toward worse people huh there's
so many badass ladies in this show oh
yeah man this is like a badass lady fest
yeah super freak show people didn't
really care for freak show from what I
understand let's the want to hit was
right it wasn't the best coven was like
I really liked coven I've been enjoying
coven I'm like halfway through so I'm
still a little bit like what [ __ ] is
happening and also that Evan Peters
story line is is thick but yeah I was
pleasantly intrigued but I love witchy
stuff like in fiction especially yeah I
was gonna say you chose wisely that's
right yeah we are the weirdos mister
everyone in the comments freaking out of
a misty day from coven Wyatt
witch she's like just a beautiful
delicious high vibration
which you like only has a good intention
yeah yeah yeah and I mean you know Lily
rabe is it just amazing like she's
always a lot of people on this show are
always terrific Evan Peters is in here -
looking like Elton John it's like Elton
John and Billy Idol crash together and
had a roughly baby which everyone on
this show is always bear but I'm always
excited to see what weird role they give
Evan Peters because Gregg says this a
lot and I do agree like he's got me on
that kind of Johnny Depp spark where
it's like I can take a weird character
and just play him you can do anything
natural about it's like as much as we
love Jessica Lange for just like being
herself every time he's just like heyou
millions he chameleons all over the
place he's a sweet delicious baby and
I'm excited to see this Elton John Billy
Idol amalgamation goodbye yellow brick
road if he doesn't sing in this I'm
gonna be that's it it'll be a secret
crossover with freak show - I wonder how
these aesthetics are gonna clash cuz you
know murder house is like a haunted
house story is a ghost story and you
have coven which is a witch story and
then there's this which is post
apocalypse not that those things can't
all go together but it does seem like a
lot of layers to merge yeah and to
isolate in this one extreme scenario if
anyone can do it it's the Murph dog yeah
I mean I feel like this is the seasons
of American Horror Story are always kind
of unwieldy but at the same time they're
always trying a lot of things and so yes
like this prospect raises my eyebrow
really high but also makes me really
excited to see what the payoffs like
absolutely no that's like in every
season there's stuff I'm just like oh he
went fitted his own universe and it's
like okay one horrific thing can we do
next you know what would your American
Horror Story be if you could do a season
you know and show run it you know what
would your theme American Horror Story
Housewives of Beverly Hills that because
that is you had you could have all the
American Horror Story you're leading
ladies together
and then you can also have every one of
the characters they played in every
other season move into the neighborhood
tagline could be there goes the
neighborhood
yes oh my god yeah to do it will take a
few cues from like a get out you know do
some you know take some high-class
horror and stuff like that makes it a
little Eyes Wide Shut you know a lot of
eyes plenty of potential there what's
the password a nice wide shot it sounds
Ryan Murphy you want to get into my eyes
wide shut parties you have to whisper it
Fidelio Fidelio there you go should be
the password is her side of the bed
available now on streaming video on
demand the DVD Amazon Prime Amazon
regular for that matter that's what we
say check it out I'm in it you're in it
yeah you meant your hand prints are all
over it
my grubby little rubbery little minutes
you let somebody else work on your movie
jeepers Christ maybe the next one well
our next project which is that rolls off
the tongue it does we need to find
what's the acronym for that we'll figure
it out we'll let you know
aah as hob comes applied to the real
region click that notification bell to
get updated every time a review or a
video is out cuz the subscriber doesn't
do that for some reason and check us out
on patreon got a ton of cool exclusive
content TV show watch lungs full-length
q a's great people people or cool come
check out the people there and i will
see you in the next one peeps peeps